for miles second up kind of in the
neighborhood but it could still at the
minute 5:00 in the morning they take all
these things of pleasure on all the
tables may have an illegal poker game so
you got all these like people playing
poker all these weird [ __ ] cool you
sit there and just like mounted it's all
I can do
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] sucked as he came on a
good night it's all I can do
[Music]
you mean
[Music]
what's up you bad [ __ ] uncle
Joey here Sunday March 12th except you
are there if the under-18 hang up right
now and shower no problems here
relatives or your [ __ ] [ __ ]
parents Lin you on the computer and you
don't [ __ ] know what's going on the
church pre [ __ ] show is here we got
weed we got [ __ ] Heinekens we got
[ __ ] liquid acid we got everything
today the DEA came in here now the dog
would die you understand me would just
[ __ ] die open that door cuz it's
getting hotter in here by the [ __ ] admit
it
well it's a beautiful day was a
beautiful weekend I'm happy you join us
we got one of the greatest albums on buy
the cars cars can do the second island
release date I don't know September 70
[ __ ] night what do you asking me
questions for can't you see I'm three
bones [ __ ] deep already you got I
can't open it for the bottle opener for
Heinekens oh [ __ ] I'm gonna move for
nice writer can I bite you yeah gave a
better full [ __ ] life I gotta do
something else to maintain I'm saying
I'm looking up [ __ ] I'm Wikipedia
narrowing and feel what it does to you
and I pay what there is a [ __ ] upside
I'm giving a better post I'm getting
[ __ ] leveled on weed again when I
tell you I'm getting leveled on weed
again I'm doing a dumb [ __ ] I'm going
back to the old school those edibles are
[ __ ] up my resistance 2000 milligrams
you can't be doing that [ __ ] every day
you can't be doing that [ __ ] every day
yeah you got a [ __ ] lighten up a
little bit Joey
because you're a different [ __ ]
situation you have [ __ ] need all the
help you Jackie them saying you need all
the help you get [ __ ]
look at that smoke coming at you from
all directions
we got platinum cush we got a bunch of
different cushions
I got cush cush Platinum cush gold cush
I got every [ __ ] cushion that you
could ever even [ __ ] imagine a
[Music]
tremendous nothing like the end of the
day smoking a bong with your family you
know I'm saying right now most family is
a [ __ ] breaking bread and telling
each other [ __ ] stories about that
careers I I'm gonna make assistant
junior clerk if I keep get the [ __ ] out
of my face assistant junior clerk and
[ __ ] most families are sitting around
right now talking [ __ ] the church family
is smoking the good stuff I'm saying
just like that I gotta switch this out
it ain't cutting it for a [ __ ] Sunday
you understand we gotta get something
with some [ __ ] open to within when I
came and Lee was listening to this I'm
like what the [ __ ] it's time Sunday
night we gotta kick this up with some
[ __ ] black people music it the cause
ain't cutting [ __ ] Brown boy this this
Danny Brown without a friend so he was
[ __ ] good dude I love that guy
it's Sunday we gotta we got a blast this
[ __ ] thing off you like the new
glasses
22:50 at CVS yeah I'm saying what's up
baby and you smoking dope just Alamos
gotta be in the neighborhood Sunday
night we're gonna kick this off the
right [ __ ] way what but I played this
to you [ __ ] always I love you
[ __ ] always it's the Lord's Day
little hop for halls and all these I'm
saying this cuz I don't drink don't mean
I don't [ __ ] drink okay just cuz I
don't drink throw me that own drink I
smoked it for [ __ ] glass inside this
time a good cold feeling a hot [ __ ]
day Jesus hose down [ __ ] give
this Porto Rican kettle peace because I
do see you [ __ ] and here's to
you and all the [ __ ] before you
may your families and you be successful
this year
don't worry about what Trump is doing
don't worry about what the [ __ ] right
is going don't worry about what the left
is doing just do what you do and it all
ends up okay you got instincts don't
worry about everybody else
[Music]
Oh tremendous a good Heineken cold every
once in a while good for the [ __ ]
head the dick the [ __ ] everything my
mother quit drinking ten days later she
was dead what's that day if you're
drinking keep drinking you gotta you
gotta add something else [ __ ] use a
penguin lookin [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] blows up for Sunday night get
this popping right [ __ ] I owe a
team that's the least I go get you a
week off started right what what he
burns nobody to stop them bondage in
bondage for Jerry's kids don't even
respect your wares that's why it's time
for the doctor to check your ass what
used to be my homie used to be my own
[ __ ] we're going deep tonight
[ __ ] break on oxycontin bunkie
you're gonna rehab next week who gives a
[ __ ] we ain't going out of business
[Music]
[ __ ] it why they look at past the bud
and stay low-key what
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
put down the middle let the little boy
go oh [ __ ] let that little boy go [ __ ]
[ __ ] what bow-wow-wow give me yo
u P oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I may be old I snuck
away no [ __ ] what what you gotta
celebrate you the exile in [ __ ] your
mama I'm talking about you and me toe to
toe oh [ __ ] I'm so pleased still in
training you know I'm saying what do you
want do open up would eat tonight
Oh is he crazy [ __ ] I called him last
night he sounds like a [ __ ] before you
can open up with 1400 he goes home on
the weekend former rubs his head and
[ __ ] you gotta look high your resistance
I wanna world my [ __ ] resistant what
[Music]
oh [ __ ] what up
[ __ ] you [ __ ] gotta start the
week off with a bang [ __ ] you gotta
you gotta come out the box the bar like
a man possessed
[ __ ] the snowstorm he understand me he
was in the Box all weekend we don't we
throw away stars I'm watching you're a
training Coxon
[Music]
so we're here were there what everywhere
he's don't worry about with your door
don't worry about what that don't worry
about we get doing don't forget Thursday
night my goobies joke house Baltimore oh
this is black music gotta respect for
the wire we shake what it don't stop oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
death row is in the house somebody down
so far we buy them at that to more than
Lee look at me son [ __ ] yeah easy
easy easy
give me the big fat dick [ __ ] don't
want to further we
I'm drinking beers in the club a
macchiato without the milk or some [ __ ]
to really get my [ __ ] blood pressure
gonna shake you might as well leave it
on its protective people they really get
my blood pressure go and talk about
technical [ __ ] that really confused me
wants to be a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[Music]
tonight nobody's doing blog nobody's
doing pills nobody's gonna be hungover
them off [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
look at me there's a [ __ ] right now you
know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
from drugs the beaches the water bucket
see something happen it's it's okay
still but something's going on I think
the weed isn't drying up tonight you see
this [ __ ]
kills me
I do I put in photo I get my weed not I
got a room just for a heater
I put the couple on the floor I come
back in 30 minutes to read is perfect
though uncle Joey coming to [ __ ] World
News Tonight suck 60 minutes hey I don't
even know what 60 minutes is usually if
I'm on my watch 60 minutes that's my
[ __ ] show but tonight I'm with the
boys I got red band Smith the [ __ ]
Sunday night if I'm drinking you smoke I
don't know I bumped my toe line now can
i scrape it up and looks like coke I'm
gonna bring it in and sprinkle on the
toe
[Music]
we love you [ __ ] we'll see you
in 10 minutes youtube.com slash Lee
slash Joey Diaz youtube.com slash c /
Joey Diaz we love you all our heart
we'll be back in ten minutes get the
Churchill what's happened now started
stay black [ __ ]